When I do a follow-up cheek swab, there doesn't always seem to be major changes. Why?
Well, I think I have a video on cheek swab testing on the member site, too.
But in general, I mean, typically, there's not always going to be giant changes, you know, your body changes gradually.
It doesn't always mean that that, you know, your body is going to call for a completely different protocol. It's pretty rare.
You might change from, you know, we might be doing one basic cancer killing protocol and change and tweak and change to something else, especially if a person's not doing good, I'm going to dig a little deeper and ask deeper questions, make sure that, you know, that something else might just be a hair better.
So don't expect giant changes. No. And again, why would a person do a cheek swab retest?
It would be if there was giant changes in their symptoms, if there was giant changes in objectifiting, let's say their cancer doubled in size or something like that.
Or if you're just okay, but on this protocol for the last four months, I just want to see if I need to tweak something.
Or hey, I've been doing really good for the last year and I don't want to take as many supplements as there's things that I can hope it.
So those are the reasons why you would do a cheek swab test and there might not always be major changes.